rookie right-hander matt peacock is your
d-back starter tonight eight appearances
in relief this year now he makes his
first career major league start here's
jesus akilar now the marlins hottest
hitter
with a man at first nobody out
down the line
and
off the foul pole he does it again
fay zeus aguilar
two run shot
two nothing marlins on top oh my
goodness
what a treat are you kidding me
93 miles an hour in off the plate and
you want to talk about a hot hitter wow
two-month single ahead of a sandia
nick ahmed gobbles that one up in front
of rojas so in the ending two runs
and a man left on base
for the marlins it is cody poteet making
his major league debut the sixth marlin
to make his major league debut this year
rojas down at third two outs and the
batter is david peralta
base hit that gets by birdie here comes
rojos d backs on the board peralta
headed for second and he's got the rbi
double
800 career hits for the freight train
congratulations on that milestone for
david peralta more importantly the
d-backs are on the board here's steven
vogt the catcher batting for the first
time in the series making his 13th start
poteet strikes out vote so poteet has
his first major league strikeout and
he's out of the bottom of the first
inning sandy leone to lead things off
2-0 from
peacock swung on and hit in the air left
center field
that is off the top of the wall and gone
sandy leone with a home run goes to the
opposite field and the marlins get that
run right back one out for the pitcher
poteet
that's the second strikeout two down in
the second now here's the pitcher matt
peacock now he's got uh one big league
at bat poteet ahead oh and two on
peacock gets him to chase
throw to first to complete the strikeout
poteet ended the first hitting with the
strikeout into the second with a k as
well and he hangs a zero here in enemy
number two
now sandy leo knew homer to lead off the
second will lead off the fourth
call strike three rings up leon third
strikeout for matt peacock shortstop now
miguel rohan
right to rojas overshift on that side of
the infield
and that's two scoreless for matt
peacock david peralta leads it
there's
off
swing and a miss pralt is down on
strikes punch out number three for cody
poteet three strikeouts no walks thus
far four poteet
wow 96 bottom of the zone and
vote comes up empty get it done young
man that's impressive
a couple of strikeouts already in the
inning for poteet
four on the night
[Applause]
roxanne fires
and a called strike three poteet strikes
out the side in the fourth and he'll
face the bottom third ahmed varshall and
most likely a pinch hit in the pitcher
spot
that one caught the outside corner
called strike three at least didn't see
me buckner's mind and ahmed's got some
words don't play it on par andrew young
three hits and nine at bats with the
diamondbacks this year all three hits
are home run
this is sky deep to left andrew young
the smasher it's three to two
he's got four hits this year all four
are homers
[Applause]
welcome back that's what you do with a
hanging breaking ball right there
so dee thought he was gonna fool andrew
young with a curveball he'd showed him a
lot of fastballs up in the zone a hard
slider away
let me roll a curveball up there see if
i can fool him and he left it right in
the middle of the strike zone and andrew
young did not miss it oh my
taking over for matt peacock left-hander
alex young who has worked scoreless
baseball and eight of his last nine
appearances and here's anderson who took
over in the ball game when diaz had to
come out
wing into this two down in the sixth
first track out for alex
the catcher is sandy leone
and alex young makes short work of the
marlins in the sixth richard bleyer on
to work
ground ball i wonder who's going to
field this one oh it's going to be meggy
and richard blair does his job nice and
easy one two three six
gets the base on balls dickerson now
he's over three cabrera backs off one
and two on dickerson now
and he struck him out swinging on the
ball into the dirt and that will retire
the side boy he carved up dickerson
and the marlins friend do not score one
hit of the ending two men left on base
it's anthony bass
for the marlins pitching in his 15th
game two away from nick ahmed
swing and a miss he took something off
and he strikes ahmed out to get out of
the seventh inning new picture for the
diamondbacks is the right-hander taylor
clark
one and two on magnuri sierra
got him
alien he comes to an end
big strikeout for clark against the
threat they leave a pair they've left
eight here's dylan floro in his 18th
game this year a 115
e.r.a one on down for pavement smith
pavon
for three tonight
high chopper up the middle and gets
thrown into center varsity takes the
turn and heads for third
that's the base hit for pavon smith
you've been in the quarters
so the tying run is now at third the go
ahead run
at first
a big strikeout for floro
and two outs in the inning
not out of the woods yet here's his
drupal cabrera
cabrera right field duvall is there and
floro dances out of trouble joaquin
soria
four
appearances this year and now trouble
for one with aguilar coming to the plate
two on nobody out
swing and a miss he chased way off the
plate he's down on strikes out number
one that ball was a foot outside
and aguilar couldn't hold up in time
he's out one out of the inning first
breaking ball he saw but
really full chased the ball it was
it was in the left-handed batters box
he's staring at the first base umpire
dory dickerson over four
here's your double play ball rojas for
one ahmed there they roll it still a
one-run game
turn it over to their closer yimi garcia
so votes aboard with the tying run with
one out in the ninth inning edwardo
escobar is going to bed castro goes
line to aguilar he will saunter to the
bag
it's a marlins win escobar lines into
the game ending double play
lo castro was on the move
and garcia gets the save